من المتوقع ان تصل قيمه الاجماليه في قطاع
المدفوعات الرقميه حول العالم الى 8.99
مليون دولار امريكي خلال 2022 واليكم
المزيد من الارقام خمسه ريونات و490 مليار
دولار من المعاملات غير النقديه من
المتوقع ان تذهب للتجاره الرقميه التي
تمثل اكبر شريحه في هذا القطار
19% فقط هو اجمال المدفوعات النقديه في
الولايات المتحده خلال عام 2020 ثمنه
بالمئه من المعاملات النقديه في الولايات
المتحده للمدفعات الاقل 25 دولار امريكي
المثير الانتباه ال 62% من الامريكيين
يعترفون بانهم اقل عرضه للانفاق الزائد
عند الدفع نقدر اما في منطقه اليورو 49%
من نسبه مدفوعات غير النقديه كانت من نصيب
البطاقات البنكيه خلال العام 2001 2020
واخيرا واحد فاصل تسعه فقد دفع بنكيه هو
متوسط نصيب المواطن في منطقه اليورو خلال
العام الماضي وهو ارتفاع بالنسبه اربعه عن
عام 2020